dass dieser bauernprotest wohl mehr ist
als kurzer Unmut über
Subventionskürzungen zeigt sich von
Anfang an die erste Reaktion auf die
Sparpläne von scholzhbeck Lindner blanke
Wut ein antiampelprotest und ein neuer
Ton den selbstfunktionäre
anschlagen wir brauchen eine anders
ausgerichtete Regierungspolitik wenn das
nicht kommt das sage ich so deutlich
dann brauchen wir einen
Regierungswechsel die Drohung sollte die
Ampel nicht alle Subventionskürzungen
zurücknehmen werden die Bauern ab 8
Januar das Land mit Protest
überziehen nur zwei Wochen später Rudern
Scholz habbeck Lindner zurück und
schmieden einen Kompromiss die Bauern
bleiben von der kfzsteuer befreit das
Agrardiesel auskommt aber schrittweise
der Preis die Ampel wirkt wie eine
getriebene die Beschlüsse aus Angst vor
Protesten im Eiltempo kassiert wenn man
lautstark protestiert dann knickt die
Regierung sozusagen ein das ist eine
Gefahr deshalb war ich auch überrascht
dass die Bundesregierung so schnell
gehandelt hat in der Richtung es deutet
vielleicht auch darauf hin wie unsicher
man auch in der Bundesregierung ist auch
der Landwirtschaftsminister sucht einen
Kurs vor Weihnachten stellt er sich
demonstrativ an die Seite der
Bauern jetzt steht er demonstrativ an
der Seite seiner Koalitionspartner und
erklärt den regierungskompromiss zum
letzten
Wort wir stehen dazu das ist jetzt ein
Kompromiss und kompromisse müssen für
alle gelten die Ampel ist dem Protest
teilweise gewichen befriedet hat sie den
Zorn offenbar nicht noch am Abend des
Kompromisses bedrängen wütende Landwirte
Vizekanzler habbeck und hindern seine
Fähre daran anzulegen ein Protest wohl
auch unterwandert von extremrechten
Gruppen die versuchen den Frust der
Bauern zu
vereinnahmen es sind Bilder die den
getreidebauernomas große rüchkamp
schockieren er ist gegen Gewalt und
fürchtet dass die Bauern den Rückhalt in
der Bevölkerung verlieren den
ampelkompromiss aber will auch er nicht
akzeptieren weil wir in den letzten
Jahren sehr sehr viele neue
Einschränkungen und Auflagen erhalten
haben und das war eben der Anlass jetzt
der in den letzten Wochen kam dass wir
dann auch noch überproportional für
schlecht gemachte Haushalte herhalten
sollen das Gefühl der ungerecht it
treibt große rüchkamp um die Bauern
fordern weiter dass alle
Subventionskürzungen zurückgenommen
werden viele fühlen sich von der
Regierung entfremdet die Ampel habe sich
hinter verschlossenen Türen geeinigt
gesprochen mit den Bauern habe sie bei
der Entscheidungsfindung nicht dem
Landwirtschaftsminister reicht offenbar
was er beim bauernprotest in Berlin
gesehen hat die Vertreter der
Landwirtschaft und auch die Verbände mit
denen wir jetzt heute gesprochen haben
sagen mit ihnen wurde überhaupt nicht
gesprochen schauen sie war auf der
Demonstration da habe ich ungefäh
anderthalb Stunden zugehört also ich
habe die transparente einzeln lesen
können ich hatte ja nun viel Zeit und
ich habe alle reden gehört die Kluft die
sich auftut zwischen Bauern und
Regierung versuchen andere Parteien zu
nutzen Hubert eiwanger Chef der Freien
Wähler inszeniert sich gerne als neuen
Bauernführer und heizt die
antiampelstimmung an es ist auf alle
Fälle eine ein Protest gegen diese
Politik dieser Ampel bin der Überzeugung
je schneller die Ampel das Feld um so
besser für Deutschland die Parteien sind
unsicherer geworden schauen sich die
Situation in den Niederlanden an wo
plötzlich eine durchaus zum Teil
rechtspopulistische Bauernpartei
entstanden ist die durchaus auch bei
einzelnen Wahlen Erfolge hatte wir haben
demnächst Landtagswahlen wir haben die
Europawahlen es ist eine neue Dynamik
drin die Entwicklung jetzt ist
unabsehbar Handwerker Gastronomen
Lkwfahrer wollen sich den Bauern
anschließen die Proteste treffen auf
eine Stimmungslage der Verunsicherung in
der eine angeschlagene Regierung
Zumutungen auf den Weg bringt